what is going on everybody and welcome
to a new video series where I'm gonna be
poking around with a robotic arm so a
company called au factory hit me up just
as I was actually moving if you haven't
noticed I'm in a new location now and
asked if I would like to play around
with their new arm swift Pro so let me
pull that one up real quick so this is
the u arm swift Pro it's kind of hard
for me to move it around right now it's
actually plugged in so all the motors
are kind of activated so that's why I
can't really move it but I'll show you
it moving later anyways it has a bunch
of what they're calling end effectors so
for example this one is a laser engraver
you can use it to engrave wood and paper
a cardboard maybe even give yourself a
tattoo I wouldn't suggest it but maybe
then we've got just you're a little
gripper claw type thing we have and open
in the camera so you can attach it for
like an on-board camera and then we have
a what looks to be a cigar trimmer it's
actually just like a pen holder anyway
all of these little end effectors kind
of work similarly and if you see that
part that's sticking out right about
there basically it's rose on on the
bottom of the arm you can see this
little silver screw you just unscrew
that pull this out slide the new thing
in screw back in it takes about 30
seconds to change the end pieces so
that's pretty cool so those are the main
ones it has it also has a 3d printer
attachment which actually is
I think it's $68 on their website so
it's actually pretty cool that you can
do all those things with the same arm
itself now the arm costs seven hundred
and fifty dollars so I know right out of
the gate and most people probably won't
be buying a $750 piece of equipment
along with the tutorial if you want to
that's fine for the links in the
description but you don't actually need
to buy the arm to follow along in this
series actually a lot of what we're
going to be doing is more like image
analysis types of tasks we'll be
training a model possibly building a
model and all that kind of stuff and
most of the time I can actually just
host the data that we would need to be
working with so you won't necessarily
need an arm to follow along but I'm not
gonna lie the arm is super cool so the
arm itself has basically four
directional movements as you've got up
and down forward and back and then side
to side now the this arm the pro version
is like super precise it's got a 0.2
millimeter repeatability so basically if
you ask it to go to the same coordinates
over and over and over how how close
does it get and it gets 0.2 millimetres
of repeatability so for a 3d printing or
for laser engraving that's really
important that it has a high degree of
repeatability so I've actually used it
to do a laser engraving project I made a
few signs for like around the house and
to do that to get a nice deep engraving
you've got to make like 20 passes and it
did just fine so pretty impressive for
what we're going to be using here for
we're gonna mostly be using the suction
cup which is actually on there right now
so this thing is actually pretty cool
too because what it does is this is
actually a really common attachment to
like robotic arms puts my first time
actually working with one and so it's
got a suction cup but it also has like a
little vacuum that just also adds you
know a vacuum so it can hold things much
much more reliably so this one actually
holds heavier objects than the motors
will put up with so the National motor
fails before the suction cup fails so
anyway so what's cool about this arm and
why I was really excited when they sent
it to me is actually you can program it
very easily with Python everything is
open sourced and even if they didn't
have a Python API you can actually send
this pure raw string commands to the arm
and you could control it that way and
you could do that with any language you
don't even need it you could
via the terminal or something anyway
let's check it out let's see how basic
it really can be and how easy it is to
control the arm and then we're going to
get into the actual task at hand which
I'm going to be using it to play air
hockey to start the other thing is since
it's so precise I've been trying to
think of ways to do a I can't think of a
good word for it besides farm but
basically I've always wanted to grow
plants that I can't specifically grow in
the environment that I'm in but a lot
like to grow food and for food most of
time you have to be able to pollinate it
and I'd like to have it be a closed
system so you can't necessarily have
bees in there or anything that's going
to pollinate so then you gotta like hand
pollinate it but actually an arm like
this could could do the pollination for
you automatically so there might be
something I check out later too but for
now I want the arm to play air hockey so
first let's go ahead and go through some
of the commands that you can do with the
arm so if you did get the arm or you
want to follow along or whatever they do
have the API they've posted here on
github and you just go there clone it
and then you just would do a Python
setup I install for the actual package
itself so once you have that we're just
going to go ahead and I'm gonna import
time and I'm also gonna from UF wrapper
not war per but wrapper swift underscore
API we're going to import the swift API
and then it's gonna use going to do that
to me there okay now so the arm is
actually so there's a lot of attachments
that you can add to the arm
there's also sensors you can add to the
arm via a Raspberry Pi or an Arduino
which actually came with the arm and so
you have the access to all the sensors
that might connect to those devices but
also the arm itself is a USB arm so the
arm itself can actually so not only can
you get it sensors that extend the arm
the arm could extend anything else - it
just plugs into
to USB so that's kind of how I'm gonna
be making use of it so I'm actually
going to at least four air hockey to
start I'm gonna have just like an
overhead camera that that pulls in the
data that we're gonna work with but
anyways it's a USB arm and so it has to
connect by this comport to send
everything but for some reason I think
either the API doesn't clean up after
itself or maybe I've got some other
program but regardless a lot of times I
get this error that it can't get access
to that port and it says access is
denied there's no permissions issue
really it's because something is using
that port I know I can go in and inspect
it or whatever but it's actually just
quicker for me to write a quick block of
code here basically what it does is just
until it gets access it just keeps
trying and sleeping 4.2 seconds so just
a kind of a hacky way to get around it
but that's how I'm doing it and then
once you've done that you can start
making API calls so I'm just gonna paste
in these API calls so since most people
aren't going to be programming an arm
along with me I'm going to do a lot more
copying and pasting especially in this
series at least any time we're dealing
with the arm when we go to the image
analysis tasks we'll see how that goes
but anyways let's go ahead and run this
and so it's timing out and then finally
got through and then we get the actual
device info but that's not interesting
we want to see the arm move so to get
the arm to actually move we use the set
position so interestingly enough set
position has two options one is a
absolute position so you've got your
coordinates X Y Z X is forward and back
Y is left and right and Z is like up
down so in this case we're just gonna
set an initial position speed I want to
say is millimeters per second this is
another kind of hacky thing I've done
here the arm can't move at a hundred at
a million millimeters per second but
there's a distinct difference between
the arms movement at let's say 30,000
50,000 500,000 and a million I found
that a million moves both the fastest
and
smoothest so I stick with a million this
causes other problems and I'll talk
about that in a minute
but for now that's what I'm using so
this will move to the absolute position
of X is 250 y 0 and Z 50 and actually
I'm pretty confident the arms already in
that position so I'm gonna add a
secondary motion so I'll just copy this
come down here paste a new one and let's
make X let's make X 150 so and then
let's make we can make Z no leaves
either so anyways let's go and run this
one oh right ok so so one of the issues
that I was going to bring up is um so
these commands are asynchronous commands
so you have a few options when you're
running asynchronous commands one is
after every few asynchronous commands
you could say swift dot flush underscore
CMD now this will in theory wait for all
the asynchronous commands to complete
let me just run that real quick though
and it actually already fin it what did
it finish it I think I hit shift enter
like I was in here the thing beep ok
that one actually ran now for some
reason sometimes it like ignores these
as if it's making the calculation of
rather than actually waiting for the
command to complete and issue a true or
something like that or an OK it just
does the math and decides when to
continue along interestingly enough that
time it wasn't a problem but I have had
that be a problem and then I just issue
like a sleep the other option you have
is to you can do a weight equals true
and that makes the command rather than
being asynchronous it makes it
synchronous but I don't believe I think
maybe this is the one that does the
calculation let's see if this one
actually works or not I'm just curious
no that one appears to have also worked
but we'll probably see later on that's
not reliable enough they so if you
really need it to make it to a certain
position you might wind up doing
something like a time sleep 2 or
something like that I'll continue along
without doing it I will use the
synchronous commands there just to see
if we get away with it 100
% so the next thing I'm going to say is
and in fact let's do that and then I'm
gonna call so we can get this little
suction cup here down here to activate
so we can say Swift dot set underscore
pump and we'll say that's true now the
interesting thing about the I thought
I'd be able to the interesting thing
about this pump is it's actually pretty
impressive it it doesn't so it doesn't
just turn the pump on it actually waits
to it turns on the pump and it waits to
return a true when until it gets the
sensation that it's pulled something and
I'm not sure like this has a slight kind
of spring to it but it's more than that
it's like the pump inside it or
something seems to know I really don't
know the answer but I do know if you
don't give it anything to grab it
actually will timeout and then it will
only carry on like this command here is
not asynchronous it's going to wait and
and it will only carry on once it's
actually grabbed something which is cool
or it times out and the timeout will not
break your program it will just simply
timeout it throws an error but you could
use that error logically from there or
whatever which is pretty cool I did not
expect that to be a possibility but
anyways once it grabbed something let's
just issue a timeout sleep for 5 seconds
and then we'll do Swift dot set pump to
false for example and let's just go
ahead and run that real quick and I'll
feed it like my phone or something so
the pump is actually on and then we'll
wait 5 seconds
maybe there it goes okay so pretty cool
now if you'll notice the the pump
actually turned on before before it
finished moving back even though we said
weight equals true even though we said
flush command it still set that pump on
immediately that's what I'm talking
about it it just doesn't listen to you
but if I set the speed to let's say
30,000 and then I'll paste speed in
there where you run it it should make
the move all the way back then it turns
on pump we feed the pump and it works as
intended whereas before it actually
turned the pump on immediately so
interesting if you ask me you know I
would hope that wouldn't be the case
that there's like it almost sounds
harder than getting the information from
the device but maybe the device is the
one that's reporting it that way I don't
know but anyways I found that to be
curious okay so the last thing I want to
show you guys is that you can also move
the arm relatively so if we instead
instead of like setting positions like
this like X 250 0 50 it will always be
that position right it's a fixed
position as absolute position but we can
also set a relative motion so for
example we could move the pump like this
so y Y so this will move I'm sorry not
the pump it'll move the entire arm over
100 I believe these are millimeters I'm
not a hundred percent positive those are
millimeters but you can also use decimal
points so it's about a millimeter if I
just inspect it visually but but anyways
I'm not 100% that those are millimeters
I'm pretty sure they are though but
anyways we can move it relatively so
this will move it just a hundred ok so
but not to the fixed position of 100 but
anyways that I think is all I really
want to talk about here what we're gonna
be doing in the next tutorial is
actually going over the actual challenge
that I want to do with this arm and that
is play air hockey with it and one of
the little promotional videos that were
playing air
keep on like a mobile app on their phone
so they were controlling it and instead
of what I want to do is use Python and
logic to at least first play air hockey
and then from there train a model to
play air hockey and then hopefully if I
play the cards right maybe you arm will
send a second arm and then we could
actually have two arms competing against
each other which would be super cool and
then we could go step further and have
users like submit their models and then
do it kind of like tournament-style see
who can come up with the best model so
anyways we'll see how far we can take it
but I think first we need to try to eat
at least just get it to play air hockey
which could be a huge challenge all on
its own so anyways that's what you guys
have to look forward to if you have
questions comments concerns whatever
feel free to leave them below if you
like this kind of material please do
support the channel this is a full-time
job for me you can go to Python program
and it's all lash support if you'd like
to do that otherwise I will see you all
in another video